and now eight more urban dictionary
definitions you need to know
lip banging excessive making out in
public everyone at the party was grossed
out by jenny and michael's lip banging
two
a perfect 140 character tweet on twitter
i'm never more proud of myself than when
i write a touch dick butterflies a
tingling sensation in the groin caused
by sexual attraction marissa is so thick
she gives me dick butterflies
fleek on point
perfect we in this [ __ ] finna get crunk
eyebrows on fleek
the [ __ ] banana polish hand lotion used
for masturbation michael got a sandy
handy because jenny was out of banana
polish side text to privately text an
individual involved in a group text
jenny and cara side texted shade during
carol's stupid group hang message
senpai someone who will never notice you
today my senpai said hi to me and my
head basically exploded i'm going to
sleep
i don't want to text you anymore lisa
wouldn't stop blowing up my phone so i
was all i'm going to sleep for more
definitions visit urbandictionary.com
while you're there be sure to look up
full donald
it's pretty clever
huh